so the newest unemployment numbers are  also in today from dieter  and they show a spike in claims let's  take a look at the numbers  over 18 000 people filed claims just  last  week and that is up 18 from the week  before  so far this year over 611 000  unemployment claims have been filed  and most of those happened during the  pandemic continued claims are also up  it's actually the second highest weekly  total in state history  at more than 346 thousand there was also  a spike in pua claims that's for gig  workers  34 000 claims were filed last week alone  and remember in the last couple of weeks  bars had a shutdown again so that has  impacted those numbers